[Musique]
voilà je me suis beaucoup à mon nom au
monsieur sans hésitation je vous
répondrais oui je laime beaucoup oui un
peu oui oui assez remercier et vous en
buvez beaucoup aubin il n'en tenait un
fraisier nombre encore plus parce que je
suis malade mais j'en ai vu beaucoup
oui un petit peu oui j'ai habituellement
marais en prendre parce qu'il buvait de
l'eau mais pas le soleil pour un repas
c'était quand même pas suffisant
pour mon âge oui j'en vois une assez
grande quantité
et est ce que vous pensez un litre par
jour oh pas tellement on repart la mini
le soir pour les repas mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien le coude du rhône
ah bon jamais pourquoi donc récemment
défendu du sien non j'en bois
raisonnablement parce que mon âge ne me
permet pas d'en boire trop et quand vous
avez vous pensé que ça ferait du bien ou
du mal du bien monsieur capi les bus
raisonnablement aussi ses prix en
quantité raisonnable j'estime que c'est
tout à fait ça fait du bien il ya 14 18
ans a pris a beau pouvoir de 1 us et qui
a gagné la guerre
et est ce que vous pensez que quand vous
en buvez ça vous fait du bien aussi ça
vous fait du mal
pour le moment ça me fait du mal aux
jambes mais ça me faisait pas mal parce
que je veux vous dire quelque chose
y en a qui disent sûrs qu'ils ont bu des
100 foot
ben moi j'ai vu des citernes demain
qu'on parlait pas ce que j'ai fait ou
guerrière léger bienvenue dans les deux
guerres et entre les deux guerres et
bien mais aussi j'aime le grain par
excellence parce que le vin est un
aliment très l'horizon
[Musique]